ا بالله من الشيطان
الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم طبعا احنا حلقه عباره عن تلقين
لطلاب مركز الايوبيه هو عباره عن ملجا غير
امن في شمال قطاع غزه نعلم ابنائنا في
داخل الملجه ان يقراوا كتاب الله تبارك
وتعالى هذه حلقه تريبا بدانا فيها من شهر
تقريبا بعد ان يعني انتقل الاحتلال الى
مناطق الجنوب لا زالت برضو مناطق الشمال
غير امنه الا انه نجمع ابنائنا بعد صلاه
الظهر نصلي صلاه الظهر ومن ثم على الحصير
نجلس في هذا المكان الغير امن هذه الحلقه
عباره عن حلقه تلقين لطلابنا كيف يقراوا
كتاب الله تبارك وتعالى القي فيها فوج
سالهم الي فيها فوج سالهم سالهم
خزنتها الم ياتكم نذير انا بقيت في جامع
العوده في بيت حنون لكن قصفوا الجيس
الاسرائيلي الجامع وجينا نحفظ في في
الملجا عذاب
جهنم عذاب ج وبئس
المص